ودائره المنافسه في المحيط الهادئ تتسع
بشكل واضح وتشمل اطراف متعدده الولايات
المتحده تاتي في مقدمه هذه الاطراف حيث
تسعى بالدرجه الاولى الى مواجهه التهديد
الصيني سيما بعد حادثه المنطاد التي اثارت
جدلا واسعا لكن ليست الصين وحدها خصم
الولايات المتحده داخل المحيط الهادئ بل
كوريا الشماليه ايضا
اثارت حفيظه واشنطن وحلفائها بسبب تجاربها
الصاروخيه المتكرره في المحيط الهادئ
التهديد الصيني ليس وحده الذي يزعج واشنطن
كما ذكرنا بل ايضا الكوريه الشماليه ايضا
وبهذا الخصوص تقدمت الولايات المتحده
باقتراح يطلب ادانه مجلس الامن الدولي
اطلاق كوريا الشماليه للصواريخ الباليستيه
وحتى المقترح على تشجيع على الانخراطي في
الدبلوماسيه وحذر من ان عدم استجابه
المجلس لمقترحها ينطوي على مخاطر وتعرض
الصين وروسيا ان يتخذ مجلس الامن مزيدا من
الاجراءات ضد كوريا الشماليه بحجه ان
ممارسه المزيد من الضغط عليها لن يكون
بناء واستخدمت الدولتان حق النقد الفيتو
ضد مسعا تقوده الولايات المتحده لفرض مزيد
من العقوبات على كوريا الشماليه في مايو
من العام الماضي
الحقيقه هي ان اولئك الذين يحمون كوريا
الشماليه من عواقب تجاربها الصاروخيه
التصعيديه يعرضون منطقه اسيا والعالم
باسره لخطر الصراع
اصيل من جهتها ظلت متشبكه بموقفها الرافض
لفرض عقوبات على كوريا الشماليه معتبره ان
الخطوه لن تساعد في حل المشكله القائمه
في شبه الجزيره الكوريه والذي لا يتحقق من
خلال فرض
العقوباترا
لفرض العقوبات لن يؤدي الا الى طريق مسدود
فاص تامل بصدق في الاستقرار بدلا من
الفوضى في شبه الجزيره الكوريه تدعو الصين
جميع الاطراف الى التحلي بالهدوء وضبط
النفس